[Music]
thank you
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook and uncensor Rishi
sune visits Northern Ireland to sell his
brexit breakthrough as a rare rubs over
whether he used the king to seal the
deal tonight the unionists say the
king's brexit tea party could put the
monarchy in Jeopardy but will it
record 45 000 migrants crossed the
channel last year with numbers set to
soar again from Spring Tory MP Kip moth
house has a plan to stop the boats
Richard Tice says the plan is nuts
they'll debate
so give nuts conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones is forced into a humiliating
apology the comments he made on this
show the victim of his lie will tell me
why it's important he did Apologize
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening for London
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored the
late Queen kept her cars close to her
chest she understood that the Majesty of
monarchy depends on dignified silence
that's how the royal family holds the
country together even as our politicians
rip each other apart but King Charles
and his laborious apprenticeship as
Prince of Wales we never quite got that
silent Telegram in the 1980s he rejected
an extension to the National Gallery in
pretty colorful terms
but what is proposed seems to me like a
monstrous car manual on the face of a
much louder and elegant friend
funny enough a monstrous carbuncle on an
elegant friend is how some people view
the Duchess of Sussex well Charles went
on to rankles to John Major in the 90s
with his views on homelessness and
poverty his black spider letters Royal
ministers with barbs about everything
from human rights to the war in Iraq he
branded the plan to send migrants to
Rwanda as appalling it's no secret that
the king is as Prince Philip would have
put it a bunny hugger is a guilt-edged
Eco warrior with an Aston Martin great
car by the way that runs on leftover
English wine and he's been very fond of
talking about it that's why it came as a
great relief when he reassured us that
once King he keep his opinions firmly in
the Royal vault
and I think it's vital to remember
there's only room for One Sovereign at a
time not two
so you can't be the same as the
Sovereign if you're the Prince of Wales
of the air
but the idea somehow that I'm going to
go on exactly the same way if I have to
succeed
is complete nonsense because the two
the two situations are completely
different
clearly I I won't be able to do the same
things I've done you know as air so of
course you operate within the the
Constitutional parameters oh dear your
majesty well few issues have strained
our political parameters more than
brexit it's toppled governments ending
careers in terms of political parties
inside out the Northern Ireland problem
has been the most vexed of the lot the
whole future of United Kingdom could
rest on the prime minister's ability to
flog his new deal to the arch brexiteers
and the Irish unionists so the king's
decision to host EU president Ursula
vandelayan at Windsor Castle yesterday
has rattled cages frankly it's smacked
of a blatant attempt to strong-arm
unionists and brexiteers who are also
passionate royalists into backing Sue
next deal it's even called The Windsor
framework and tonight the dup Samuel
Wilson launched an astonishing and
predictable broadside against Charles's
involvement in the deal claiming it puts
the future of the entire monarchy at
risk
I don't know whether it was his choice
or whether the government persuaded him
to do it but I think it's a very very
dangerous
position for him to have taken it is a
bad decision and if he keeps going down
this route and politicizing the monarchy
then the status that his mother had he
will never acquire and he will put the
monarchy in my view in Jeopardy because
people will simply see it as a partisan
rather than a National Institution
well this debate will only intensify
next month the King's first state
visitors Monarch will be to France and
Germany the great power Brokers of EU
and not a traditional pilgrimage to the
Commonwealth it's a far cry from the
brexit dream of global Britain with
trade deals burnished by Royals voyaging
on a new Royal yacht we don't know
whether Rishi sunak is wielding the king
to get brexit done or if the king
himself was itching to get involved but
this is the future of the Union could
hinge on Northern Ireland the future of
the monarchy actually could hinge on the
king keeping his vow to be silent about
politics and keep his nose out of it
it's in everyone's best interests I
believe if he does that well joining me
now is historian Sir Anthony Selden
journalist and friend of the queen
consort peshadow Wyatt and all through
the windows at War Alexander llama
welcome to all of you Alexander to start
with you
it distract me that this is very good
for rishi's sunac if you're trying to
get your deal through positioning the
new monarch of the United Kingdom as
somehow supporting all this is great
politics great Optics
it's great though if you're King Charles
in my estimation and you want to make a
statement about impartiality which is
what his mother was of course renowned
for but what I think is very interesting
is that the call didn't come from 10
Darling Street to bring in King Charles
for the meeting with us you know it was
from Buckingham Palace do we know that
we do know about it right it said
yesterday that this is from Bucking
Palace not from Downing Street which is
really to me even more problematic to
quote the word of the of the Millennium
I think it's deeply problematic because
I think for what essentially King
Charles is saying is no I'm bored of
being on the sidelines I want to go into
the center I want to have my voice heard
and he listens for man who as you said a
second ago was the black Spider memo man
this is the person who's always always
wanted to have his voice hurt and now we
can see that his sitting down University
for cozy tea together is something that
essentially he's saying I am involved in
this I want to have professionally you
want to get involved in this
possible I'm interested in what you say
but this is not quite what I've heard
and as we know that the the Monarch
cannot meet a political leader without
the PM's permission I heard that um it
did come from Danity and he was happy to
do it and he is simply carried I mean
wait a minute can I just finish yeah you
can but I want to just on that one point
I think either way the fact is he did it
so whether it came originally from down
the street Charles has been around a
long time
before you finished my point is it
doesn't really matter actually to the
Optics the Optics are he did the meeting
yes and this in my opinion it flies in
the face of his vowel not to get
political no it hasn't it hasn't because
he cannot avoid meeting political
leaders and hosting them his mother
hosted monstrosities he she hosted
Robert McGarvey she hosted Nikolai
church it's not very very difficult he's
not implying that Charles by hosting
ursia vandelayan is somehow sanctioning
a pro EU if he does it on the very day
that the British prime minister
announces his new proposal he doesn't
foreign
[Music]
you know your history better than any of
us put together
has this happened before
not like this no uh and therefore it is
uh without precedent the Monarch has
always seemed distasteful people
sometimes uh they became distasteful
after they were seen so it is
um interesting territory and I would
agree with Patronella that he would not
have seen it without the prime
minister's endorsement and he is clearly
below the uh the Prime Minister I did
read today may have even been the
spectatorship I did read today that in
1974 Edward Heath persuaded the queen to
go to France to endorse our entry into
the EU so that if that is I I wasn't
aware of that if that is true and that
was what happened in the way that it was
reported that would seem to be not
entirely different to this and doesn't
that therefore appear slightly undermine
your argument that this was without
precedent well it would make me think
that I was surprised the queen did that
and maybe she shouldn't have done
I don't think the monarchs should ever
get involved with but we saw the huge
round when it was reported that the
queen veered towards a view about
Scottish independence
claim at one point that she was
pro-break right but these things they
could be very self-serving those planes
but my point is the monarch has to be
impartial because the model represents
everybody in the United Kingdom not just
singular groups of people who supported
but the monarchist do is that Charles is
doing his best in my view was it was it
was it smart timing is the real question
well I look I think that history will
judge this to have been a wise and a
prudent thing because peers this is
where we'll disagree again because this
brexit thing has gone on and on here is
an agreement this is my view which
um
which brings together most of the nation
Northern Ireland for goodness sake voted
to remain uh we just need to get over
with I mean we're on board with brexit
but we need to move on the reason I have
a problem with the timing Alexandria is
that this is not a done deal yet this is
a proposal from Rishi soon now which has
the support of the EU but the real issue
will be say the dup decide you know what
we're not having this deal and they
reject it then you have the king
supposedly embracing all this and then
the dup saying forget it excuse me
ready deal because ultimately Rishi has
raised the game a bit since Boris
Johnson's lamentable effort yeah but the
reality is is for King Charles probably
shouldn't but uh yesterday because the
Optics of it if a short-term Advantage
is that the Windsor agreement sanctioned
by the king it looks something which is
given the stamp by The Establishment
before Parliament
and we don't know what the dup are going
to say we don't know what we don't know
what the awkward Squad of conservatives
are going to say I mean I'm sure we're
all waiting with baited breath for Boris
Johnson's view on it I see I I can't
think of anything I'm waiting less
Boris Johnson sticking his big nose into
this once again as you said you just
finished a Tome on Boris Johnson
that you're gonna have I had to put the
final test drugs today today
um which I hope is a is in in some way
reflective of a wider closing of the
chapter on Boris Johnson because I felt
he in his tenure he was actually very
damaging to the office of prime minister
in many ways and I tweeted today not
from a political perspective or partisan
perspective
um because I've actually voted for both
parties over the years but I did tweet
that it's I find it reassuring that in
Richie sunac compared to his two
predecessors at least we at least have
somebody who looks conscientious
eloquent and intelligent and thoughtful
like he's trying to think this thing
through it and also quite Collegiate in
the way he's embraced the EU to try and
get a deal done to get through all this
okay
um I think that's what history will say
look Boris Johnson had an amazing
opportunity after brexit to make
Britain's new role in the World remake
to remake the government he blew
everything he didn't even get brexit
so history will say that Boris Johnson
had an opportunity blew it because he
wasn't serious enough didn't know what
he wanted to do didn't know how to take
people with him didn't know how to be
prime minister uh and wasn't serious
enough the only bonus to Boris Johnson
is that it turned out his immediate
successor was even worse
well history I mean you will be part of
how history judges Boris Johnson will
history be very scathing with him I
think history will see it as just an
incredible wasted opportunity from
somebody who had in in significant ways
he had the ability to connect with
people he was a a funny great amusing
orator he made people feel good he had a
great spirit about him he had a sense of
the country but he couldn't put it into
practical policy he couldn't make
breakfast I've interviewed him I've told
the story before it's worth repeating I
once interviewed in the GQ Magazine when
he used to do interviews not run into
fringes and hide and I said do you know
Boris I've always said that lurking
beneath the buffoon exterior lies a
really smart calculating political brain
and I think you want to be prime
minister and he went with very kind of
your business he said but you must
consider the possibility that lurking
beneath the buffoon exterior lies an
actual buffer which I thought was
actually very impressive yeah you know
Boris better than most of it especially
that is partly true I mean but Boris
Boris thinks but he doesn't think deeply
and he gets bored with things terribly
easy uh like women unfortunately
excuse me no comment no comment to talk
but the trouble is that as a prime
minister he was a disaster waiting to
happen because he's not conscientious he
um is not Collegiate
um he doesn't believe in compromise and
he doesn't like boring hard work the
truth is Alexander it was always all
about Boris right so and it drove him
let's be fair a bit like Donald Trump in
America that kind of you know caricature
populism drove him to the highest office
in this land as As Trump did in America
doesn't mean it's a good thing the fact
is is that we should look at Boris in
context with his fellow oldertonian
Prince Harry they're both people who
reached for the Sun and they never quite
got it because what they thought they
could achieve was to essentially take
this institution in Boris case prime
minister in Harry's case for monarchy
and tear it apart yes but institutions
exist for a reason the reason why Boris
failed so dramatically was because
ultimately he was weak and he thought he
was strong he thought he was charismatic
but Boris also fell because Boris
simulatory in the sense that they he's
not a whiny brat like him no no but they
don't I mean to be fair to him no he
doesn't mind excuses I know he confuses
celebrity with doing a job
um
and he thought he was editing The
Spectator and you can't run the country
like a general business
you got more towels coming on next I
mean serious people
um there he had in City Hall he just
didn't know how to use people in numbers
I mean I do think well I interviewed
Richardson at number 10 last month and I
I did find his seriousness reassuring
yeah like this guy you know he may not
survive the next election simply because
of where the conservative party is but
this is indisputably if this deal goes
through that is a massive series
massive launch pad for it for a grown-up
and it's a great pretty he won't get a
chance
said today his most significant
political achievement he'd seen this is
97 right and I thought that was very
interesting yes because this has cut
through in a way that very little hands
since brexit actually I was looking at
yesterday and thinking when's this going
to dissolve when's this going to fail
and it didn't dissolve and it didn't I
agree and and just finally answering on
Richie sunac there are still potentially
just just under two years to an election
is that enough time historically you
look at all the previous elections is
that enough time in the cycle for him to
turn things around to use this as a
launch pad for the Brave New World of
the conservative party potentially yes
but no prime minister has ever won five
elections on a trot for their part since
1832 never been done one party doing
that so it makes it really hard I
suspect you'll end up being a really uh
sound competent prime minister who
despite all that will end up losing it
not unlike John Major who turned out to
be much better prime minister and he
might as he thought he might find he
could still he could well you might find
also that a few years of being in
opposition yes yes as Leaders
conservative party against Kia stamba
who will inherit a very difficult
situation probably may not be the worst
thing that happens for his ability to
transform the party if he's willing to
stay on yeah I mean
yeah yeah it's always have to start
ripping each other apart yeah great
debate thank you all very much thank you
great to see you all we're coming next
tonight transit in Italy is more than
100 people are feared dead in a migrant
boat disaster how do we prevent these
kind of things happening on Britain
shores as the channel crisis here
continues to escalate
thank you
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember it thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no out with the people's Channel don't
worry every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to Piers Morgan on sense of
a deadly consequences of a small boats
crisis has been laid bare again with
fears that a hundred people including
many children have died in a shipwreck
off the coast of Italy with nearly 3 000
migrants are crossing this channel in
the first two months of 2023 with
warnings as many as 85 000 could make
the journey this year at this rate
Richie sunac has promised to tackle the
issue head on my next guest reckons he
has got the answer proposing an exchange
agreement between France and the UK
we're joining me to discuss his plans a
conservative MP former cabinet minister
Kip Moore house and reform UK leader
Richard Tyson it must be said things
this idea is completely crackers so this
should be a good debate um tip Morehouse
simple terms what is the idea so
essentially appears as you know the the
trade across the channel is incredibly
dangerous you've highlighted today the
the risk to life and limb but it is
basically prosecuted by organized
criminals right who are trafficking
these people from where they've come
they pay money to come and this is a
business right and so everything we've
done in the channel so far military
cooperation I don't agree it's all
failed yeah yeah it's all failed and the
reason is because the gangs basically
just alter their price and even if we
arrest again they're replaced by other
gangs so and even if we change their way
in yeah
right so the key thing I think we're
going to all agree on all that so the
key thing is to remove their ability to
cross in the first place they haven't
got a product to sell so that would mean
that um the moment somebody lands either
is on the beach or in the sea or on our
beach they get returned to France at the
moment quietly because of military
Primacy in the channel we do intercept
about 95 of people crossing either on
the beach in the sea or on our beach so
we return 100 of them now why would the
French every single one every single one
gets returned immediately so there's no
product nobody crosses
I just on that point even if they're
genuine asylums yes they just have to be
returned because it's a separate
question about what they should be
allowed to stay what we want is to save
lives in the channel so we have to stop
that route how do we persuade the French
to do it well we say to the French tell
you what in exchange every person that
we return we will take a settled Refugee
who wants to resettle in the UK in
return from within who qualifies by our
criteria IR criteria and then we take
people in a control way now the key leap
of faith is to realize this is that by
returning everybody
nobody will think it's worth Crossing
and so we won't have to do any excuse me
naive we won't have to do an exchange in
the first question no I don't think so
really you think you think they'll all
just stop I think they will if you can't
get across and don't forget as I say
we're intercepting 95 96 but I can look
before I get to Richard I can see the
immediate floor here unless you're
guaranteed when you get returned to be
one of the lucky ones who then gets
picked no no why does it stop it doesn't
really necessarily it wouldn't be the
same people with these are so France
already hasn't existed I understand that
but if you're desperate to get away and
desperate to come from France into the
UK in any way why does it deter you if
you're not going to be one of the ones
who then gets plucked and brought here
well because you've paid whatever money
to the gang and you're not succeeding if
you stop the boats if you catch yeah
which we are doing 95 of the time the
reason that manston is so full or has
been in the past is because we're
intercepting nearly everybody okay is
that figure right 95 that kimballhouse
says
it's probably definitely over 90 right
and the truth is so we are stopping the
vast majority we're not stopping no no
we're controlling sorry we're not
because they know they're going to be
put in nice accommodation they're going
to be so what is the actual floor the
floor in this argument is it will do
exactly the opposite what will happen is
the people traffickers will say to
people all over Europe come to France
and you might get the big lucky dip of
going to the very generous UK
um
the second thing but on that though are
you saying that it would disperse the
problem to other parts of Europe no
it'll it'll it'll basically act um
France will act as a bigger magnet from
the 300 plus thousands who are coming
into Europe that's the first problem the
second problem is the people smokers
will say you still want to go to the UK
because I'm going to get you there you
won't be apprehended we'll land you in
the middle of night whereas currently
the land you're about between 10 and 12
in the morning so you get apprehended
and then you'll disperse into the black
economy but the UK is still a great
place and you've got all the levels two
valid points yeah so on the first one of
course and I realize it's difficult to
get your head around it sometimes if
we're not if we're intercepting
everybody and returning 100 and nobody
will cross which means we won't take any
exchanges so the pull into France
wouldn't be there because nobody is
being exchanged because nobody is
crossing so in the initial stage in the
first few months we might have to take a
few but then we're in no worse position
because we're swapping one for one of
the French are in nowhere's position
either but critically it removes the
ability to cross and therefore the gangs
have no product to sell but now but on
your point about diversion you do have a
point about diversion in the one of the
problems that the government's had so
far is that everything they've done they
haven't predicted what the gangs are
going to do in reaction and so we would
have to look at interception at night
you know much greater presence on the
French beaches particularly at night if
people did attempt those crosses and
critically also do a deal with other
countries because it's only 50 miles on
the Belgian Coast uh it's so obvious Kip
Moore has why is it why have you waited
until now to come up with this master
plan why is nobody in the brains of the
British government conservative British
government and many many years now not
come up with such a simple solution well
I have been talking when I was in the
cabinet before I have mentioned it
before and talked to a number of people
in number 10 about it but you know the
way the government works these things
take time to surface I'd said it in
private and I say in public
um and I think it you know the other
thing just to say is that the reason I
want to say it now was because on the
10th of March where she has a summit
with the manual macron the first summit
for some time between the UK and French
leaders
um and you know they will under
doubtedly be talking about this issue
and I can't see in the short term and
you're right that this summer may be the
worst on on record for numbers
particularly given that the government's
got legislation coming through so the
game
one of which you see the next five
pledges to me which he well he repeated
them to me made them public obviously
but when I interviewed him in Downing
Street one of them was come back to me
by the end of the year and we will have
substantially reduced a number of
migrants coming over if it gets to 85
000 this summer this could almost be a
resignation issue for us it's the states
are high the state you make it one of
your five big places it's already 100
more than last year which was a record
Year we're only two months in where we
agree is you should pick everybody up
and you safely take them back to France
and you say to the French will have a
joint processing center and we will
process them rather like the UK used to
do 15 years ago within a fortnight the
genuine legitimate claims who have been
persecuted then we would accept them the
rest would be immediately returned from
where they came that is the only way
they stopped see paradoxically that does
give people an incentive to cross
because they'll get crossed they get
returned they get but they get depends
immediately people who are crossing
effectively we have to remove the the
chance that they will get the objective
of what they're coming for that there's
some reward for going that route now
there's a whole other conversation to be
had about how refugees access this
country and we obviously have some
bespoke routes but whether we want to
that's a separate conversation my
primary objective is to stop people
crossing because we don't want bodies I
mean the army of all this it seems to me
is that yes it's clearly an increasing
problem yes it's potentially absolutely
tragic if we just seen in Italy 100
people dying we don't want anything like
this to happen a course on our Shores
however we also have an acute lack of
legal immigrants in our country right
now right I mean this is the irony is
that we're making all this noise and
fast and debate about actually a
relatively small number of people when
you talk to anyone in the hospitality
business in particular restaurants bars
clubs and everything they are crying out
for legal immigrants to come into the
country because last year was a record
lawful immigration 1.1 million gross 500
000 net the population's never been
higher that is a completely flawed
assumption the right statistically work
in the NHS yes because you ask people
who work in hospitals why is that it's
because we've got 5.2 million people on
out of work benefits a million and a
half more than pre-covered for too many
people work is not paying you've got to
make work pay we've got to get two
million of those five million back into
work it's also true a lot of look after
them also sure a lot of people working
those businesses they went back home
during the pandemic and they haven't
come back that's true
well certainly there are um sectors that
are struggling for people there's no two
ways about it and Hospitality I think is
yeah is one of them I mean the home
office would say to you that they've got
I mean I'm not at the homeless anymore
but they would say to you they've got
specific schemes for example with
agricultural seasonal workers they've
got schemes to allow people to to come
in but the whole idea of of uh the new
immigration system was to allow us to
pick and choose the skills that we
thought we needed in particular areas
but as um Richard says you know one of
the things coming out of the pandemic is
we do have a higher than normal people
who are economically inactive for
various reasons we're trying to discover
why I think Jeremy Hunt said something
well because they're bone Idol well it's
very simple work doesn't pay you've
frozen the time we've encouraged a work
sign mentality people can stay at home
and not put in the yards in they used to
and they're being embraced for it if
anyone complains about it they're
accused of toxic bullying and an
overgenerous furlough scheme for too
long absolutely accentuated that yeah I
want to just very clear this is you on
the daily politics that I happen to be
watching and one of your
Jackie Smith the former labor Home
Secretary was on as was Israel Oak shot
your other half Richard uh and Jackie
who's the chairwoman of the Joe Cox
Foundation obviously set up after the
appalling murder Joe Cox the the female
labor MP but she was on to talk about
the foundation civility Commission
and the only reason that I chuckle as I
say that is because this is what then
happened
I'm told that this was all sorted that
we were now in the sort of open Waters
of brexit that clearly wasn't the case
excuse me hang on hang on hang on hang
on let's not let's not this thing
hang on hang on hang on hang on Civility
and politics
your example of politeness and politics
and the re oh come on
was that the best way kit Morehouse for
Jackie's mess to make the point about
civility well I think that's what they
would call an unfortunate incident I
think um obviously Jackie's temper got
the better of it she did actually to be
fair to her apologize later I'm not
surprised she's on to promote civility
they've never said to Isabella you know
I wouldn't survive exactly exactly we
were all very taken aback uh by the
that's what I call a a spectacular
political owned goal yeah I think
exactly
is an important one as you know it is
but maybe Practice What You Preach yeah
exactly on the small boats idea just
dwell on it most people have dwelled on
it for a few days and thought Ashley do
you know what maybe once you get your
head around the logic of it it doesn't
stop the money I'm gonna say guys I've
got to finish it but the point I would
make is I think nothing has worked so
far I don't think the Rwanda plan will
fly because the numbers will be far too
small so we've got to come up with
something so at least I was I saw the
saying when I ran the Daily Mirror he's
a morning conference there is no such
thing
as a bad idea the only bad idea is
acting on a bad idea but bad ideas often
and this may be a good one but bad ideas
often me sometimes feel a good idea the
enemy in this situation is no ideas
right so I just think the more ideas out
there the better because frankly nothing
at the moment is working so let's have
another idea thank you both very much
indeed for this uh coming up after the
break conspiracy theories Alex Jones has
been forced to apologize to a Sandy Hook
uh relative of one of the victims for a
vile lie that he repeated to me on
uncensored about that victim's relative
in the shooting Scarlett Lewis his
six-year-old son Jesse was murdered at
Sandy Hook we'll be here next
thank you
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember it in thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel don't
worry every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at 7
pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
oh
this is talk TV
[Music]
well earlier this year I interviewed
Alex Jones the world's most notorious
conspiracy theorist who made millions of
dollars peddling sick lies about the
Sandy Hook mass shooting
it was a horrific incident which 20
children six staff were murdered well
Jones told his many followers it was a
government hoax a deep State plot to
justify seizing Guns For The Grieving
families were actors every time he lied
he made more money but Justice caught up
with Jones the Sandy Hook family sued
for defamation they wiped the floor with
him he's been hit with damages of more
than 1.5 billion dollars so what are
they interview well he's influential
continues to spout conspiracies
unchallenged to millions of people
online challenging people like Jones is
in my opinion more effective than
pretending they don't exist there's a
direct result of that interview Jones
will sit with another legal rebuke from
Scarlett Lewis a grieving mother who's
done more than most to hold into account
for his Sandy Hook lies this is what he
said on the show
when I was in the Texas trial you can
look at this
they had uh one of the mothers on who
lost her son and I went on my show that
morning and taped it before I went to
court and I said I think she's real I
think her son died I'd seen her
testimony the day before and I'm very
sorry that Adam Lanza did this and then
she went on the stand and said Jones
attacked me and said I'm an actress it's
all fake today and I walked over to her
during the break and I said watch my
show from today your lawyers lied to you
and the next day she came up and cried
and shook my hand
and Scarlett Lewis and said oh my God
it's true I I saw you did say that so
there's a lot of manipulation here
well they said it wasn't a manipulation
because after a complaint from Scarlett
Lewis Alex Jones then had to issue a
groveling apology
I do not wish to harm or damage Miss
Lewis in any way and if she does not
agree with my recollection of her
response to me I will defer to Miss
Lewis recollection of her statements and
I do not wish to cause them any further
grief harm or embarrassment
well I'm joined Now by Scarlett Lewis uh
Scarlett great to talk to you again I
just wanted to get you back on so that
you can just once and for all clear this
up because when he said that I wasn't in
a position to know if that conversation
had happened but it turned out to be
another one of his lies
hi peers uh it's it's nice to be on your
show again yes uh every every
interaction that we had was actually uh
on videotape we had I think it was
broadcast on YouTube to the world and so
everybody saw what happened in that
courtroom and there was never that
interaction ever uh and he even got the
uh the the the times wrong uh yeah it
just never happened I mean the lies just
don't stop he has the potential to do so
much good and uh I don't know why he
continues to lie does the fact that he
issued this really by his stand is
pretty groveling retraction
um does that suggest to you that perhaps
he is beginning to realize that words
have consequences
well he is definitely beginning to
realize words have consequences because
we held him accountable for that but
again if you listen to what is supposed
to be a retraction or an apology it is
it is never going all the way he is uh
retracting with another lie and uh
it just it's uh it's it's very
disappointing because you know I feel
like every day that we get up we have an
opportunity to what we call what I call
now in my movement Choose Love be part
of the solution there's so many things
that are going wrong in this world and
uh he's got such a following he has such
an opportunity to do what's right and
have the courage to do that and he just
he hasn't done it yet you know Scarlett
thank you I was in New York last week
and then I was in Missouri in Dallas in
Texas uh the week before doing various
interviews and I just noticed a
statistic there have been 80 mass
shootings I wear four or more people are
hit by gunfire in America this year so
far well not even in March yet and in
the UK by comparison there's been one
which was a gang-related drug Gang
Related thing where nobody died and last
year I think one person died in a mass
shooting in the UK and obviously there's
no comparison culturally between gun
ownership uh in modern America modern
Britain but when you see those kind of
statistics
what will it take do you think to change
the thinking in America because 18 mass
shootings in under two months just seems
to the rest of the world to be
unfathomable
well it really is and the fact that we
can have uh 20 first graders in two
first grade classrooms and six Educators
be massacred in an elementary school
that happened 10 years ago my son being
one of those six years old six-year-olds
that is unfathomable as well and it
continues to happen over 350 school
shootings in the past 10 years and I
really think at this point uh it's it's
what I started advocating for 10 years
ago is not going to be a law it's not
going to be a pill nothing as easy as
that we're going to have to address the
root cause of the suffering that leads
to violence substance abuse mental
illness and all the other escalating
diseases of Despair and that's what I've
been attempting to do for the last
decade in the Choose Love movement well
you do a fantastic job Scarlett and it's
great to talk to you I remember talking
to you around time of the Sandy Hook
massacute was one of the saddest things
I have ever ever had to report on and
the courage of you and other parents
honestly was it was incredibly inspiring
whilst being also utterly heartbreaking
and what Alex Jones did to compound your
misery and compound the morning process
and make it worse not better I thought
was unconscionable so I'm very glad that
you all took action I'm glad he's being
held to account we'll see how much he
ends up paying but he's certainly been
made to account for his words and made
to realize they have consequences and
I'm grateful to you for coming on to
talk about at least at least part A Part
retraction from him for once again lying
about you but this time in a court of
law uh thank you Scarlett great to talk
to you again
thank you
extraordinary people uh I can't even
imagine can he going through something
like that just imagine it the child six
and goes to school and never comes back
riddled with bullets
and it happens again and again in
America
well next tonight a question nobody has
ever asked before is satire dead
could be we'll debate with comedian Matt
Ford plus my pack next
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture
there's no subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you we're leading Britain's
conversation oh no uh with the people's
Channel no what are you uh every little
helps for God's sake is nothing original
anymore it's finger licking Goods I'm
loving it look let's be honest we don't
have any fancy speech writers here but
we do and I promise you discuss the
issues that matter to you yes I'm back
talk TV not with Morgan just before him
Monday to Thursday at 7pm join me just
do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
and coming up on The Talk The
transgender rapist that Sparks a row
about women's prisons is sentenced to
eight years behind bars gilet Maxwell
will appeal her sex trafficking
conviction in the United States and
schools saying they're not getting
involved in social media spats it's up
to the parents to take control of their
kids online that's all at nine o'clock
foreign
podcast host Matt Ford is touring with
his spitting image live show idiots
assemble one of those idiots of course
is me
uh but I also think you're right if
you're in spitting image you've made it
alive he says desperately we'll come to
that in a little moment um Matt great
good welcome you to the uh to the pack
uh how do you feel about being part of
peers's pack nervous you shouldn't be I
don't feel nervous at all no no maybe
I'm so disarmingly calm about it I don't
know what's going to happen now let me
ask you as a comedian I've had this
conversation with other comedians lately
is real life becoming almost impossible
to parody is the world going so nuts
that actually it becomes almost
impossible to Lampoon it I don't think
so I think I can see how people think
that but purely from my point of view
working on shows like spitting image and
impersonating people I was doing
political comedy at the time of Nick
Clegg and Ed Miller Band where you know
people would come to political comedy
shows but having Donald Trump and Boris
Johnson being able to impersonate them
peers
yeah what's going on here and having
having like big characters everybody
you're in the fake news media appears
you're a bad person very very bad and
I'm sad about what happened between us
you know what he does Trump when I used
to interview him the thing that used to
really really annoy me it was so
difficult when you interview is when you
interview about this and he keeps saying
as you know as you know Pierce and it
says something completely outrageous and
I know you agree with me it's like what
do I do it's a technique he does yeah
and it's incredibly dangerous because
you he loves you in yes because as as I
know you think too you know it and says
something terrible but that's what he
does a lot of flattery up top
whenever he's anywhere it's great to be
in France and Paris which I think is
still the capital of France by the way
it's a great place he used to always
introduce me as my champ because I want
Celebrity Apprentice uh and I literally
was his Chapman if I mentioned it before
um but so every time I spoke to him he
became president of the United States I
rang him in the Oval Office to hear the
president is that my champ and I was
like I can get used to this uh I've seen
distances myself from that obviously um
it's interesting because I Bill Maher in
America is one of my favorite uh hosts
over there and he talks often about how
the the right used to be the rich
material vain for left comedy right but
now he said the left woke have become so
nuts that he finds most of the funniest
stuff is from lampooning the woke
nonsense well I always took them account
of both sides I never saw the sense in
restricting myself to just dealing with
the Tory party if you look at what
happened to the labor party in the last
few years plenty has gone on I mean and
it can still also tease people that you
would vote for no kids time is someone
that I think is really common to
politics now but I personally can't stop
a piece I think it's important that the
government realizes that's very good you
can still impersonate people that you'd
vote can you do me because Rory I'll
tell you why because Rory Bremner once
said to me I'm one of the more difficult
people and he said it's people like you
Simon Cowell Gordon Ramsay you have
these kind of they don't have much in
their voices actually quite Bland
non-accented voices do you have that
problem no I would describe you as Bland
no no I was horrified but he made a
point that they're actually more
difficult to to to do the impersonation
you know sometimes it's meeting with us
I've never impersonated You Luke Kempner
does you very much
um but being near you there is
definitely a sort of squeakiness that
you can sort of now that's just the
first that's the first person you can
tell sometimes be I remember
interviewing William Hague and obviously
many people can do William Hague but it
was only when I interviewed him over as
he kind of hungs in between
word I thought sometimes it is just
hearing that they used to do me on
Saturday Night Live In America he's ever
go Richard
let's I want to just play a clip this is
George Santos the U.S congressman in
America who tells more lies I think than
anyone even Boris and Trump were
together and it's a clip of what he said
when I finally said well just admit what
you are
I've been a terrible liar I mean would
you be prepared to say that sure like I
said well I've been a terrible liar on
those subjects
what does he say about life that this
guy's sitting in Congress and he's I'm a
terrible liar and that's the only
truthful thing he's probably never said
that anybody can remember
um what does it say I think it says
masses about uh congress's inability to
get rid of people I mean if that
happened in the House of Commons surely
they would that person would be forced
to resign I don't think that's generally
I don't think anyone could seriously be
an MP and just admit in a television
interview I am a terrible liar and get
away with it well I don't know we we
have had some MPS that have been
to be Liars I will actually brazenly
admitted almost proudly I'm a terrible
well maybe that's just the power of you
interviewing him please
like you know you know the house I'm now
trying not to squeak because of him
literally you start to think well I'm
now I'm going to start squeaking we're
not allowed to call people lies in the
House of Commons even when it's obvious
that people are liars we're a very
strange quaint country I think I hope
we're more honorable that you couldn't
carry on being an MP if you'd admitted
that you were a liar but um I don't know
anymore I think Boris Johnson has kind
of blown everything up is this I mean
are we living in a post-truth society
now where I hate to say that but are we
living in a place where people like
Boris Johnson and Donald Trump a large
constituency of people don't care if
they tell the truth I think that's
probably always been the case it was
just that those people ended up in
positions of power that effectively
people used to regulate their own
behavior in a way that perhaps modern
leaders haven't but if you look at Rishi
soon I can care someone whatever you
think of them politically that is
definitely a return to politics more as
normal it is and actually I mean you've
got to say Richard whatever side of the
Divide you're on they're both
serious-minded people with serious
backgrounds they they're not buffoons
they they take their jobs seriously
they're conscientious they're hard
working you know I just think I I do
feel reassured by that I'm kind of done
with the buffoon caricature stuff oh I
think the country's done with the
buffoon caricature stuff without
question and people want serious
politics we've got some massive massive
challenges ahead of us
um but it's interesting you know neither
of them are great characters but they're
both diligent they're both trying in
their respective ways do we need a great
character to run the country I think
everyone would just like do we need
competence a bit of stability and a bit
of Integrity which we have had neither
of and you know I think there is a sense
that Boris Johnson's a winner because
he's charismatic and that's why people
vote for him and I think people have
seen through all of that I think people
just want someone who can get us out of
this terrible mess that we're in on so
many different levels in terms of brexit
in terms of the strikes there's so much
that an intelligent sensible mind can
can get their teeth into
um I think that's what the country wants
and Boris won because he was up against
Jeremy corbyn yeah and because Richard
did him a favor you know there are
reasons why Boris won it wasn't purely
that it was had he been up against a
decent opponent and not been trying to
get brexit through I think things would
have been very different but Richie
sunac is an interesting can you do him
kind of you know he's very energetic you
know I think that's pretty good right
and it's a lot of management speak you
know ours is a government of integrity
and professionalism and accountability
and I think people say hey guys that's
what we want which is the ones
when you're on your tour and stuff uh or
did a podcast and you start doing your
impressions which is the one that is the
biggest grab please so it used to be
Boris and Trump they were the ones and I
would say Trump right to the end
you've got to do that by the way because
by the way it may not be the end we
might say you might see him back in the
White House people are saying it's the
greatest ending ever appears in every
one of those people you're a mick Jam
when he actually looked at his own
inauguration and saw half the size crowd
that was there for Obama I said it was
the biggest crowd ever seen when he was
asked he went digital
because people have watched online but
it is hard to follow in terms of if
you're construction a comedy actually
who's the big crowd pleaser now at the
moment really the moment I do care
stomach honestly don't you say the Prime
Minister accept I think it's funny
because no one else is doing it yeah and
it's obviously Boris was impersonated to
death as was Donald Trump so when
there's someone new around and you've
maybe speak you're doing an
observational comedy about a person's
Behavior even the way he has his hand
out I promise just questions at the
Metropolitan Police and the way that he
says certain things can can Kirsten
carry through two more years and win
this election or is Rishi soon that got
his Gander up with brexit now getting
the deal actually done uh I think Rishi
sunak if this is the base level of what
he had to achieve in in order to stand a
chance I think with Nicholas sturgeon uh
no longer being in position it's a
really unique uh uh position for
kierstama it's it's his to lose he's got
to show us what country he wants kids
done he's got to stop now being the
opponent and B this is my vision the
country judge me accordingly uh great to
see you Matt come back that was great
love everybody
need a laugh don't we need to laugh
absolutely you put some yards in today
good to see you thank you and Jenny
lovely to see you as always well that's
it from me whatever you're up to
remember the most important thing in
life Keep It Uncensored good night
foreign
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about